[Music]
let's move on now to the new drama
surrounding the film all the money in
the world now we know the call to
replace Kevin Spacey with Christopher
Plummer and getting all the actors back
to reshoot those scenes those came at a
price and now there's a report claiming
the movie makers paid leading lady
Michelle Williams far less for reshoots
than co-star Mark Wahlberg I don't have
any money this headline from USA Today
is pretty blunt wahlberg got one and a
half million for the reshoot while
williams got less than a thousand and
action that means that for the 10 days
michelle would have been paid less than
1% of what mark was paid i don't think
this is about money this reported salary
gap infuriated hollywood coming in the
middle of The Times up movement which in
part bites gender inequality and was
topic 1 at Sunday's Golden Globes
Jessica Chastain quote she deserves more
than 1 percent of her male co-stars
salary Eva Longoria agreed we are linked
in arms with all the women here Michelle
had said in December that she'd do
whatever it took for the good of the
film I was on the front line I was like
you can have my salary you can just take
it like that's not why I work if that'll
help you you can have it and you can
have me break and you can have whatever
like I'll just be there the reshoot also
happened over the Thanksgiving holiday
ridley was like we gotta reshoot this he
was gonna reshoot the movies I said ok
well cancel Thanksgiving now what's very
interesting here is that both actors
made significant sacrifices to get this
movie made Marc took a substantial pay
cut in the beginning when he first
signed on and Michelle clearly
sacrificed for the reshoots book the
product the finished product is
fantastic they did a great job with this
movie
[Music]
you